foreign
is the world in which the story of
Diablo takes place and it's the
Battleground for The Souls of humanity
and the fight between Angels and Demons
Sanctuary is a vast world now always be
something new in every area like hordes
of enemies Safe Haven towns resources to
gather events quests and more
we wanted to bring Diablo for
artistically more back towards like
Diablo 2 the much darker style it's very
Macabre the artists and designers have
had so much fun working on it and it's
just been a joy to create for us
how would the people of sanctuary show
their world what kinds of art would they
use to describe the world one of the
things we really wanted to do was make
the game feel like a painting everything
was built by a wonderful group of people
who love Diablo as much as you do
we have five unique zones each of the
regions has its own kind of flavor and
ambient life we take a lot of influence
from what our concept artists give us
and I know they take a lot of influence
from real life
there's Kazakhstan which is the sort of
desert it's amazing with its sweeping
sand dunes scosglen which is inspired by
Scotland fractured Peaks is inspired by
the Carpathian Mountains the dry steps
is sort of our mountainous desert region
and how is our is the swampy region of
the South whether you're on a mount or
on foot it's a joy to go from one region
to the next also the region transitions
are really beautiful and stunning to see
making sure that it felt sort of
geologically true was really important
if you walk from fracture piece into
hausar you'll cross all of these
waterfalls caused by snowmelt so you can
actually see the snow melting in
fractured Peaks through waterfalls
entering into Houser and entering the
large Basin that fills houses are with
all of the swamp water we have all the
different environments in the Overworld
and we tried to make sure there was some
parody with those in the dungeons we
have dungeons that are flooded and
there's like moss everywhere it very
much fits in with that skoscon
environment Kazakhstan is All Desert so
we have dungeons filled with sand all
the dungeons are particular early place
to make sure that they feel like this is
a thing that could be in this part of
the world it fits here it belongs here
we definitely redesigned some of the
monsters for example the fallen family
has gone through a major redesign to
make them feel more Grim a little
scarier a little darker to match the
tone of Diablo 4. monster families are a
way to describe the group of monsters
that create a combat experience a lot of
times they'll be fruits and swarmers
melee or casters and that's the term
that we used to sum up the vampires or
the drowned or the undead and all of
them have unique abilities but they all
synchronize together they bolster each
other and improve how they work on the
battlefield so that every time you fight
a pack of let's say goat man it's always
different we wanted to make sure that
the monster families all felt like they
fit in their environments and so our
creature team did a really good job of
making these different versions of them
that have adapted to their environment
there's snowy goat men and fractured
peaks in some of the colder areas versus
lightning goat men around dry steps and
kind of the more arid areas how is our
has a lot of poison spiders each of the
regions has its own kind of flavor and
it's pretty exciting to discover we have
some really cool new snake men the
nangari we've seen snake been in Diablo
before but these guys are just really
twisted amalgamations of multiple snake
heads even human body parts we have
skeletons we have Undead we have ghosts
all the things you would expect to find
from a Diablo game spiders have been
around in Diablo forever but the spider
host was a cool new twist it's a giant
spider that attaches to a corpse and
then puppets sit at you and when you
kill it it explodes with tons of baby
spiders and then those little spiders
come after you and I feel slightly
guilty about traumatizing a lot of
people with it we also have Wildlife
deer snakes bugs dogs you can pet the
dogs by the way so many people ask to
pet the dog it's actually a lot of hard
work to figure out how to put that thank
God
you have so many activities that you
might run into it could be a stronghold
it could be side quests you might have
key dungeons to do there could be
bounties to pick up you might encounter
a world boss you might encounter an
invasion event of some kind we have much
longer sort of narrative heavy side
quests and we have some shorter side
quests so you never feel like you're
always doing the same thing the pacing
is always a little bit different one of
the things that I really loved about our
announcement was the by three they come
cinematic I was able to build a quest
where you actually get to go to those
places you get to go to the town you get
to go inside the chapel and I work with
some incredible dungeon designers to
build the dungeon from The Cinematic
you're going to get to go across the
bridge that you saw to the actual room
where Lila was summon I don't spoil too
much but I'm super excited to have
players see it sometimes it's kind of
nice to just walk places because that's
a lot of the times when you see these
little events you might find a demonic
altar that you need to feed your blood
to to summon demons to then defeat for
all of their loot you might find a ghost
child who's trying to find the remains
of their parents and you have to protect
them we have strongholds which are a
sort of large area that you can enter
and it has its own story its own setup
its own sort of art that sort of tells a
very specific story about this location
and those stay unlocked permanently once
you've beaten back the darkness we did a
lot of figuring out the balance between
like how much space do we need for
players to play through these dungeons
versus how much space do we need to make
them look cool my favorite is this one
called endless Gates it's got these
teleporters and these teleporters
actually take you to other dungeons so
you'll end up in cave a crypt or one of
the Ancients and every time you go in
it's designed to change
there's dozens of villages and towns
that you will run into the cities and
towns are designed to be clubs they're
they're Havens they're places where you
can find other players they're good
places to do all of your usual Inventory
management each region has its main city
that you can get lots of side quests and
lots of activities we've really crafted
the world to feel like there's always
something just around the corner to find
in Diablo 4 you actually get to walk
Sanctuary it's a massive place that you
can seamlessly explore but no loading in
between zones which is something brand
new
it's a very immersive experience what I
love about it is that you can go in a
direction and you might be searching for
a particular Quest or an item and you'll
come across a stronghold that you
haven't explored before you'll come
across dungeons that have legendary
affects where you might discover a side
quest that you didn't even know about
that fills in some bit of lore that you
actually were interested in there's any
number of things that can happen along
the road to your destination and that's
what I love about having this fast space
there are tons of different types of
events in the world it's been created to
feel full of things to encounter full of
secrets to discover full of characters
to interact with those stories to find
we have these altars to Lilith that if
you can find them they will give you a
permanent buff to all of your characters
across the game there are tons of them
hidden everywhere we also have these
massive World bosses that are so big the
camera actually has to pull out even
further and you're going to have an
opportunity to fight these bosses with
your friends or with strangers to take
down these huge World bosses and the
team has done just an incredible job
making Sanctuary world worth exploring
and a world worth investing yourself in
[Music]